uh i want to play for you an incredible
clip this is this is i i just love this
this is so good
there is an activist and student at
dartmouth college named i hope i'm
pronouncing his last name correctly
jack cocharella
he uh went to an event with radical
extremist republican congressman madison
cawthorne who continues to claim that
donald trump actually won the election
in 2020
and our friend jack confronted madison
and it's really hero's work this was at
dartmouth
cothorn is reduced to a stammering mess
unable to put together a coherent
explanation to defend his position let's
go right to the video this is really
really good
so i just had a quick question for you
uh congressman cawthorne a majority of
republicans believe that president biden
was not lawfully elected
now you know that he was and that he won
the 2020 election so when will you stop
lying your constituents admit that
donald trump lost and end this senseless
attack on our democracy so first of all
it's it's a loaded framing of the
question but for the format for what
jack's trying to do
it's absolutely perfect
well number one
number one i can only one whole heart
disagree with you i i believe the
election oh the facts you disagree with
here on what was that um
on the facts that president biden was
lawfully elected absolutely well let me
go into it right quick there's an
unconstitutional election here you
propagate the big livestream
okay so as you can all see in article 2
section 3 of the constitution the only
people who have a right to change
election law in the united states of
america are the state legislatures you
saw in six key states namely wisconsin
and arizona as the worst perpetrators
the state uh policy the state governors
and
now he's wait hold on who was it that
did the elite legal thing that of course
does not mean that donald trump
was it the governors who who i don't
know no but yeah trump definitely won
board of elections there who actually
went around the wheel of the
state
legislature
wait a second so was it the will of the
people or was it the will of the state
legend who what was violated exactly
madison chain's election laws on their
own that is unconstitutional when you
have voter drop boxes that are set up in
parks when you can get rid of signature
verification or voter identification
laws that is against the law and some
possible unconstitutional
[Music]
[Applause]
were you against them
[Music]
this kid's got upper management written
all over them jack cocharella
really really well done and of course
the stuff that madison cawthorne is
saying we've heard it so many times
before
and it's sort of a gish gallup when you
throw it all together well there were it
was against the constitution
the u.s constitution and the states
changed the rules and it wasn't the will
of the people but it wasn't the will of
the legislatures but actually it was the
legislatures who changed and when you
put a drop box in a park or change the
magic
hold on a second
how does this mean trump won
let's look at these issues one by one by
one and listen this corn
he has his talking points prepared right
he's been he's been perpetrating this
lie
and and um perpetuating the talking
points for a while now so he knows the
talking points but in a format where you
can really take them one by one and pick
them apart you see that there's nothing
there
every single one of these liars should
be questioned and they should be facing
exactly these questions
every time they appear in public
explain exactly
how it is that trump won number two
explain exactly how you talk about the
constitution in terms of the election
but you never mentioned the
anti-constitutional attempt by the
january 6 rioters to stop the
certification are you for or against
that ex explain it it should become
impossible for these people
to evade these questions every time
they're in public uh and a really really
great job there by jack coacharella a
generation z activist and student at
dartmouth college
and uh my my guess is we'll be hearing
more from him
and hopefully i mean at every town hall
at every opportunity these people should
be asked these questions you've got to
be prepared you've got to be prepared
with rebuttals because they're going to
have some rebuttals but really really
nice job we're going to take a quick
break and we'll be back after this
one of our sponsors is shaker and spoon
the monthly cocktail subscription box
delivering ingredients and recipes for
artisanal cocktails i've been using
shaker at spoon to make cocktails at
home the last two drinks i made were
citrus paradisi
because i'm a big vodka fan
and sea fog with rum the whole
experience begins when you open the box
everything looks really nice they
include all the ingredients you need
except the alcohol with easy
instructions i've been really impressed
with the results even if you know
nothing about mixing drinks like me you
will have a ton of success creating the
cocktails that shaker and spoon sends
you and you learn about mixology in the
process and widen your horizons it's the
perfect thing to do for a date night
i've had a ton of fun with it i think
you will too and you'll get twenty
dollars off when you use promo code
pacman at checkout go to
shakerandspoon.com
pacman the link is down below